ça y est après des mois d'attentes
nabila a enfin accouché du petit millan
son premier enfant qu'elle vient d'avoir
avec thomas vergara le fruit d'une belle
histoire d'amour qui débute en 2013 sur
le tournage des anges de la télé réalité
à l'époque tous les deux candidats c'est
le coup de foudre immédiat c'est
physique on s'attire comme des aimants
et qu'on se pose mille et une questions
principe peu de gens misent sur la
longévité de leur couple les mois se
suivent et l'histoire semble solide
malgré leurs deux caractères volcanique
en 2014 c'est le drame suite à une
violente dispute conjugale
nabila dérape la jeune femme passera
cinq semaines à la maison d'arrêt de
versailles et la pression médiatique
devient de plus en plus présente
il décide donc de quitter la france est
de prendre du recul en s'installant à
londres après toutes ces épreuves et
sept ans de vie commune
nabila est thomas semble donc ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre de leur histoire plus
magique que jamais une bonne nouvelle
même si l'accouchement n'a pas été de
tout repos selon thomas vergara ça a été
très très long et très compliqué pour
l'accouchement le col de nabila ne
souffrait plus au bout de trois jours
d'attenté c'était très douloureux pour
elle ils ont décidé de faire une
césarienne
nilan et donc un petit garçon de 3,6 kg
pour la maman semble déjà très fier je
viens de vivre le plus beau jour de
toute ma vie
ce que je ressens aujourd'hui est
inexplicable mon mari et moi sommes pas
présents par an je ne trouve pas les
mots pour décrire notre joie nous sommes
comblés d'amour merci à mon mari qui a
été exemplaire du début jusqu'à la fin
tu es toute ma vie je t'aime tellement
nabila et thomas une belle histoire
assez unique dans l'univers de la télé
réalité
j'adore comme à capote en plus mais il
donne des ailes il donne des détails
détail des détails vont faire on attend
la tête de ma mère je croyais qu'il
était alors oui vous dire un truc je
voulais dire un truc
il appelle un taxi oui j'ai oublié
harkis dessinée qui a construit quel
architecte de la pyramide du louvre par
nabila je crois que c'est bing et céline
ont fait mais j'ai plus c'est pays doit
être
elle a fait un jeu d'ailleurs la bonne
et ils ont expliqué sur les réseaux
sociaux qui voulait déménager à dubaï
pour élever leurs sur leurs enfants et
je sais que vous aimez beaucoup jessica
ti venant des majors et accoucher elle
avec son mari thibault ils ont donné
naissance à un enfant le 7 octobre et
elle a fait des vidéos aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux en pleurant parce
que ça fait une semaine que qui sont
toujours à l'hôpital parce que le petit
a une malformation nombre de l'oesophage
et apparemment il devrait être sorti
d'affaires mais je sais vous voulez mais
beaucoup l'effet des goodies ou jessica
merci en tout cas oui
[Applaudissements]
alors moi j'ai très française un petit
coup de gueule quoi évidemment pas
pareil mais on s'en doute qu'elle a fait
naître son enfant en france pour qu'ils
aient tous les soins français la
nationalité française et trois jours
après où une fois qu'il a insulté le
parc vivre à dubaï
mesdames à dire qu'enfin elle habitait
déjà dû à l'eau non non il aurait pu y
vivent là il aurait pu naître là bas
donc la baleine société va gagner son
argent là vivent là bas si faits sont
injustes et j'ai le droit d'avoir cette
année l'enfant va être trop deux jours à
paris la nationalité donc quand tu as un
souci un problème médical alors il sera
français est en revanche pour gagner du
pognon et sera dubaï vous n'êtes pas au
jas précis moyennement la démarche c'est
le vrai dubaï chinatown qui naissent à
dubaï mais je hais ce que je suis le
seul à voir ce coup de gueule
non j'ai ouïe merci merci jean michel
rabat riche avec toi c'est vrai bon
alors ça peut passer le prix rfo voilà
oui là vous chercher la paix oui non